Debbie Reynolds has died  et can confirm the legendary actress  died after suffering a possible stroke  on Wednesday while discussing plans for  her daughter Carrie Fisher's funeral  Carrie died from a heart attack just one  day before her mother's medical  emergency Debbie was best known for her  acting roles in How the West was won and  singing in the rain Reynolds  successfully made appearances on stage  in television and film throughout her  career and was nominated for an academy  award for best actress in 1965 for her  starring role in the Unsinkable Molly  Brown anyway as we say mass evo coup in  2015 the Screen Actors Guild honored the  icon with a Lifetime Achievement Award  you  [Music]